[Music]
it's time to take your plane bending
into the world of anti-spin does it
sound like I just put together a flow
Arts Mad Lib well you're not actually
that far off but I swear this is
actually a thing and we call them
anti-bent toroids drexier from
drexfactor POI sharing with you the love
of poi spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain and in this video
I'm going to outline the techniques for
learning this very cool but forgotten
corner of the tech POI world before we
dive in though I just want to give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyro Terra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that I've got
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to non-business
friends of the channel Johnny Howard
Lane machinsky and Becca becklinen thank
you all so very much for your support
from my work and my mission things that
I have learned in the past couple months
y'all really like your toroids like a
lot I've done two videos on them and
y'all keep asking me for more and hey
your wish is my command a couple months
ago we took a look at isobene toroids so
this month I'm going to break down for
you how to perform anti-bent toroids if
you're new here please show the channel
some love and subscribe I post regular
tutorials on POI spinning flow arts and
flow culture so be sure you know when I
upload a new video so to start let's
quickly recap what toroids are so we can
have some context for our anti-bends
toroids are an exotic corner of the tech
POI World wherein we attempt to move the
plane the prop is spinning in just like
we would the prop itself most often
presenting the plane of the POI in
profile to the viewer like a straight
line and bending between neighboring
planes the classic example of this is to
imagine the plane of the POI as being
like a hula hoop that hula hoop can move
through a path that looks a bit like a
donut and we can spin that hoop various
ways within the donut if we spin the
hoop in the same direction the hand is
moving and complete a beat at the same
time what we're creating is an ISO Bend
I already did a tutorial on those and if
you want to catch up I'll leave a link
to it down in the description but you
can also spin the plane in the opposite
direction that the hand is moving in if
that hoop or instead flattened down to a
staff we would call this motion
anti-spin and hence it's referred to
here as anti-bend instead and a strange
property of antiben toroids is that they
result in the POI always spinning and
bending along the outside edge of the
donut so how exactly do we create an
anti-bend well it's going to require
both some Theory and some practice and
we're going to have to talk about the
difference between beats of the plane
and beats of the POI let's say for the
sake of argument that I'm going to
perform what would be considered a four
petal staff anti-spin with the plane of
the POI this will involve flipping the
plane to switch which side of it faces
the center of the donut four times easy
enough to visualize but how many times
are we going to have the POI spin
through the course of this how many
beats will the POI itself complete as
the plane is moving we can add or
subtract beats to our hearts content but
a lot of versions of this idea wind up
looking pretty messy in most cases we
tend to pick one of two options for
Beats of the plane versus beats of the
POI either we do twice as many beats
with the POI so it spins twice for each
time the POI plane flips or we perform
an equal number of poi and plain beats
here's what each of those look like a
common way to do four petal anti-bend
toroids is to perform an additional beat
at each of the four Compass points I
usually refer to these as Grace beats
because they give the person performing
them an opportunity to stabilize the POI
planes before bending them again but in
three petal anti-bent toroids it's way
more common to perform only one beat of
the POI for each Bend of the plane
resulting in shapes that look like the
outlines of polygons by and large four
plane bends is the Threshold at which
switching between these orientations
starts to make sense at greater than
four bends the degree to which the plane
has to bend each time makes it more and
more helpful to take a pause at each
point to stabilize the POI at less than
four bends adding the grace beat starts
to look a little sloppy and redundant as
for four bends themselves I most often
do this with Grace beats but it's
certainly possible albeit challenging to
do it without your mileage may vary okay
so with all that said let's actually run
through how to perform those two
examples and get some antiben toroids
under your belt starting with the four
petal anti-bend just like when we were
learning the iso Bend we'll start with
the POI spinning full forward and Buzz
saw plane along our Center Line down
near our hips as the POI spins down away
from the center you'll bend the POI
slightly off to your right and as it
swings out away from you you'll then
bring it back into horizontal plane
spinning it clockwise if you were
looking up at it from below did you
notice that something kind of strange
happened there if you've done my isobend
tutorial you'll know that one of the
ways you Orient yourself with
isobandoroids is that the POI will
always be swinging either away or toward
you through the middle of the toroid I
refer to the difference as being Audis
versus innies but when we perform one of
these bends in an anti-bent toroid we've
switched the movement to the POI from an
Audi to an innie that will happen every
time we move to a different position in
anti-bend cool so now let's try to bend
from our right side up to the top as we
spin our POI in horizontal plane we wait
until the POI spins out away from us and
we bend it up onto a diagonal away from
us before letting it drop back into
buzzsaw plane at eye level spinning
reverse if we look at this from the
front you'll note that as I'm performing
this Bend I'm keeping my hand just
behind the plane of the POI so the POI
is moving just before my hand between
these two positions so we go from my
hand being under the horizontal plane to
it being just to the right of the high
Buzz saw plane so to recap we started
with an Audi bent it to an innie and
then bent it back to an Audi the top and
bottom will be the same orientation and
the sides will be the opposite
orientation but just know that in
anti-bend the opposing sides will always
match cool now let's Bend off to the
left we once again wait until the POI is
spinning away from the center of the
donut and as it begins spinning towards
us we Bend off to the side when it spins
back out away from us it should arrive
in a horizontal plane spinning
counterclockwise if viewed from above
just like with our last Bend I'm keeping
my hand just behind the plane Lane of
the POI going from having my hand to the
right of the buzzsaw plane to having it
hovering above the horizontal plane so
again we've arrived at an innie from an
Audi and the left side matches the right
side our final Bend is going to require
us to bend the POI from the moment it's
pointed out away from the center and as
it spins out away from us we bend the
plane downward and as it swings back
toward us we pull it into buzzsaw plane
spinning forward at our hips back to
where we started for this last Bend I'm
going to skip my hand ahead of the POI
plane at the bottom in Buzz saw planes I
like having my hand on its native side
even though it breaks the pattern of the
rest of the anti-bed flower so now that
we have all these individual bends down
we can practice moving continuously
between them to start maybe perform
three grace Beats at each compass point
and then bend to the next one then work
your way down to just two Grace beats
and then finally down to just one in
each spot if you want you can take the
grace beats out entirely it's
challenging but not impossible and what
you'll find is that you're spinning the
POI for about half a beat on each
diagonal as you go around now one thing
that's really important to point out is
that the fact that we arrive back where
we start with the POI spinning in the
same direction is mathematically
dependent on there being an even number
of Beats so what happens when there's an
odd number of Beats the pattern switches
Direction every time you perform it it's
a total trip and that's our cue to take
a look at the three beat toroid or as
it's sometimes called the toroid
triangle now this is going to require
much different thinking to get through
instead of thinking of Buzz soft planes
and four Compass points we're going to
have to adjust our thinking to
visualizing something more like a weave
with three points to it start by
performing a two beat or Tic Tac in
front of you and point it upward Towards
the Sky notice how the shape of it has
changed relative to the audience from
looking like a figure eight to looking
like an upside down U or V as the POI
comes down on your left hand side I want
you to let it swing inward towards your
stomach and switch into a horizontal
plane as you look down at it the POI
will appear to be spinning
counterclockwise let's see that again
from POV you want to make sure the Cross
Point of the POI in the two beat is
directly above your hand rather than
straight out in front of you as it would
be in a traditional two beat again when
it hits the bottom of the left side pull
it inward toward your stomach and bend
it into a horizontal plane spinning
counterclockwise now how do you get back
to those more vertical planes hang out
here for as many beats as you need and
then watch that point where the POI
swings over to your right when that
happens pull your hand up and bring the
POI plane more vertical and once again
into a two beat or Tic Tac it should now
feel like that Tic Tac is going reverse
instead of forwards the direction of the
pattern has changed make sure to keep
your hand close to Body Center as you're
performing this bend the POI should come
up just past the hand to the right so it
has room to go back and forth across
each side of the hand also we should
return it to a spot where the Cross
Point of the two beat is pointed up cool
now how do we get back to where we
started just like we did when this two
beat felt like it was going forward wait
until the POI is coming down over at
your left side but this time swing it
out away from you into a horizontal
plane it should appear to be spinning
clockwise as you look down on it from
above for reasons I'm still not clear on
I feel like my planes tend to bow out
more on this reverse 2 beat keep an eye
on this as you make the switch and try
to keep the planes more or less straight
to really nail that triangle shape and
now on to our last step hang out here in
horizontal plane for a few beats and
then when the POI swings over to your
right side pull it upward with your hand
into a more vertical plane and you
should arrive back at where you started
doing a forward Tic Tac pointed up
towards the ceiling or sky here that is
again from the front again have some
care with getting back into those
vertical planes and make sure to keep
them looking straight to preserve the
image of the a triangle I know it's
totally weird but it'll make sense with
repetition and practice I promise start
out by doing three forward Tic Tacs
before bending into a counterclockwise
horizontal plane performing three beats
and then bending into three reverse Tic
Tacs and bending into a clockwise
horizontal plane for three Beats
then do two forward Tic Tacs into two
beats horizontal counterclockwise to
reverse Tic Tacs into two beats
horizontal clockwise then just do one
rep of each and you should arrive at a
point where you're seamlessly bending
around the full triangle I know it feels
super weird but these patterns look
super cool when you do long exposure
photography or Trails video with them
you get something that we rarely get
with POI otherwise straight lines and
pretty clear shapes the more you
practice the cleaner and more defined
you can get them and if you're looking
for one more challenge to Noodle your
Noggin one of my favorite uses of toroid
triangles is actually to perform them in
a hybrid with the other hand performing
a triquetra this results in a triangle
juxtaposed against something that looks
triangular but is built out of Curves
very neat effect and of course my
favorite use for anti-bends is to
perform a pentagram using these
techniques doing this with anti-spin
looks cool enough but the pentagram
isn't super clearly defined with
anti-bends on the other hand the shape
reads loud and clear long exposure
photographs of this make for great
Christmas cards as with isobends
practice these in all timing and
Direction modes to unlock freedom of
movement with them see what cool things
come out of that
[Music]
did you get anything out of this video
please make sure to like comment share
and subscribe to help other people find
it and to help my channel grow this
video would not be possible if not for
the wonderful support of all of these
amazing people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon and they
along with the people listed down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on my channel possible
thank you one and all for all of your
very very generous support
do you like my videos do you like my
flow sessions Vlogs reviews Combos and
more I am on a mission to try and bring
POI spending and flow Arts to The Wider
world and help people connect with their
brains and their bodies so help me do it
head on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up you can do
that at the link in the description or
the card that just popped up if you're
watching on YouTube there you can get
access to a whole host of awesome
rewards and help me along in my mission
do check that out please and thank you
want to check out some of my other
videos on toroids I'll leave a link to a
playlist of videos I've done on the
topic down in the description as well as
up on screen if you are watching on
YouTube the YouTube algorithm also
thinks that you'll like this top video
based upon your past viewing habits so
maybe give that a look too make sure to
get out and flow today and I'll see you
with a brand new video on Monday thanks
for watching and have a good one